I was listening to an alternative practitioner online who said she only uses adaptogens short-term because they work on the endocrine system and she doesn't want to create a dependency on them.
Does this mean there are some kind of negative feedback loop for adaptogens? Do you agree they are only for short-term use?
There is not a negative or positive feedback loop for adaptogens because unless you are giving a formal itself.
So for instance, if you have low thyroid and you took a thyroid formal which would be in the form of a drug
so let's say you were taking, you know, synthetic T3, T4 combination and getting a scythroid.
So if you're taking scythroid and that's a replacement for thyroid.
So let's say you had primary hypothyroidism and you've been on scythroid.
Well, scythroid is going to create a negative feedback loop but it's going to turn off your thyroid and you're going to become dependent upon it.
After a period of time being on it. So that's exactly what this person is thinking about.
Let's ask you this question and that's correct thinking.
Is there a negative feedback loop for adaptogens though? No, because it isn't the horrible.
So if you were giving a hormone then your to a Terry and your hypothalamus would be sensing a normal level of hormone.
It would basically shut off the organ.
So if you were giving a hormone, that's the case.
So what are adaptogens?
So adaptogens are adaptogens as a classification of herbs that help balance your hormones.
If they're too high meaning if you're in a adrenal fight or flight mode they can bring it down.
If they're too low meaning if you're in a adrenal insufficiency mode it can bring it up the same herb.
So they can help you adapt in difficult situations hence the name.
However, there are some over the culture and one that I could think of off the top ahead.
That is not an adaptogen but is also many times by practitioners classified as an adaptogen and that would be DHA.
Say DHA is you could purchase that as a supplement.
People buy it all the time and they think it's a good adaptogen for adrenal stress but it's not it's not an adaptogen.
It is a horrible. So I don't ever recommend DHA unless the person.
If you do a adrenal stress test and it's they're just completely flatlined meaning.
So if you've done an adrenal stress test you know what it looks like you have to have this specific curve.
But if someone is in complete adrenal fatigue where their adrenals are completely shut down they'll be flatlined.
And they may have you know symptoms of they can't even hardly get off the couch even during the day.
Then using DHA for a very short turn is what I would do and that's what I would use.
A bad product a product short turn because it is a horrible and it does function.
Your body will be affected through the negative feedback loop and could actually just shut down the adrenals if you continue on it.
But adaptogenic herbs do not do that. So is there a harm in taking adaptogenic herbs long term.
But they in effect shut down the organ. No, they can't. I'm going to an adaptogen that also has desiccated.
Glangular isn't it. So like an adaptogen that also has desiccated adrenal.
Could that basically function as a negative feedback loop?
No, could there be forebode present in desiccated adrenal gland?
No, I would say no. Could there be forebode present in desiccated thyroid? I'd say possibly yes.
Could that then function on a negative feedback loop?
Possibly except I still would if a person had low thyroid they're trying to avoid you know either taking a synthetic thyroid.
Replacement or they're trying to avoid increasing the dosage of synthetic thyroid replace what I would much rather have them be an undesicated thyroid.
Are they going to be dependent upon that for the rest of their life? Well, most likely if you have primary hypothyroidism that isn't going to improve you may have to you are helping support the thyroid by giving desiccated thyroid.
Is it is it supplemented in a replacement for that thyroid? Well it possibly could but you're you are that's the only way you can get that person over that help.
Are they becoming dependent upon desiccated thyroid?
Possibly not at all like you're giving a hormone itself so long answer to this is if it is not a hormone and it's in a truly an adaptogen that you're not going to have a negative feedback loop and there's no harm in taking it long term.
I'm giving a desiccated product still there's very little chance except maybe the thyroid desiccated thyroid and in that case you still you need to do that anyhow so there isn't any other you know way to you know so you're going to go on replacement which is definitely going to shut down the thyroid so I still don't think if you're taking a true adaptogen you're going to have a negative feedback loop and there's not any harm in taking it long term.